[Música]
quem tem medo de tubarão
quando nós olhamos pra esse animal
cinema nos ajudou a construir algo que é
muito poderoso destrói embarcações
destrói vidas e é extremamente perigoso
no cinema também a outros vilões mas o
tubarão especificamente vocês sabiam que
a probabilidade de você ser atacado e
morto por um tubarão é uma em três
pontos 7 milhões
é mais provável que você ganha na loto
fácil do que você ser atacado e morto
por um tubarão ficou fácil né
o sistema também a outros vilões que
também são conhecidos pela destruição
principalmente robôs de máquinas
inteligentes que conhece o exterminador
do futuro
todo mundo praticamente mas quando nós
olhamos a forma como os robôs são
aplicados atualmente no nosso dia a dia
nós nos deparamos com essa imagem esse é
o pepe é um robô humanóide que está numa
casa de repouso de idosos lá no japão
ele auxilia esses idosos a fazer algumas
atividades físicas e obviamente traz
alegria pra casa
além do pp
existe também o roberto é um robô urso
que auxilia no processo de locomoção
principalmente naquelas etapas em que
isso exige maior esforço dos cuidadores
como por exemplo no processo de levantar
da cama de levantar de uma cadeira
além do rapper e do roberto existem
vários outros robôs que são aplicados no
nosso dia a dia para trazer uma
interação melhor entre as pessoas
trazendo carinho atenção e diversão e
até mesmo contribuir no processo de
ensino aprendizagem
a robótica faz parte de um grande
guarda-chuva chamado inteligência
artificial e inteligência artificial
está mais presente no nosso dia a dia do
que nós imaginamos
quem é que veio para o evento utilizando
algum aplicativo como google maps ou
heysel qualquer outro aplicativo de
motorista particular
a grande maioria das pessoas
quem é que existiu alguma recomendação
de vídeo do youtube ou alguma
recomendação do netflix houve alguma
música recomendada pelo spotify legal
o feed de notícias o fim das suas redes
sociais
a análise de spam da caixa de entrada
dos seus e mails um assistente pessoal
como a síria ou o google são exemplos de
utilização de inteligência artificial no
nosso dia a dia
as empresas também têm utilizado a
inteligência artificial para estabelecer
uma relação com seus clientes oferecendo
um atendimento mais personalizado tanto
via voz quanto via texto
além disso os médicos têm utilizado a
inteligência artificial para auxiliar no
processo de diagnóstico de doenças e até
mesmo na recomendação de um tratamento
para esse diagnóstico
ele tem inteligência artificial
específica para auxiliar na criação de
obras de arte da criação de músicas ou
até mesmo na criação de trailers e nós
não podemos esquecer também tem
inteligência artificial está sendo
aplicada na educação possibilitando que
as instituições de ensino forneçam um
processo de ensino aprendizagem mais
personalizado e adequado para as
necessidades dos alunos
de fato a inteligência artificial está
totalmente presente no nosso dia a dia
a gente nem percebe a inteligência
artificial
atualmente tem um grande crescimento por
alguns fatores
o primeiro deles é o poder computacional
poder computacional que a gente tem hoje
é muito maior do que a gente tem a 10
dia 10 anos atrás
além disso o acesso à tecnologia está
cada vez mais fácil
quem é que tem um aparelho como esse
o smartphone tem um poder computacional
cerca de dez vezes maior do que a
máquina que levou levou o homem à lua
é impressionante a inteligência
artificial já existe faz tempo
alan turing do pai da computação
publicou um artigo em meados dos anos 50
deixando a comunidade científica será
possível as máquinas pensarem e pensar é
uma característica humana uma
competência humana e assim como pensar
várias outras características são
capacidades humanas
isso nos leva o conceito de inteligência
artificial que é a capacidade de imitar
a inteligência humana e quando eu falo
de inteligência humana eu tô falando do
ato de falar e de ouvir de enxergar de
raciocinar deduzir e até mesmo aprender
nós aprendemos de diversas formas
diferentes pesquisando algum conteúdo
novo ouvindo uma palestra como essa que
nós estamos aqui no ted ou aplicando
esse conhecimento tirando suas próprias
conclusões e inteligência artificial o
processo de aprendizagem de criação de
uma inteligência artificial é semelhante
ao do processo do ser humano que você
possa construir algo com inteligência
artificial
diferente dos modelos tradicionais é
preciso que você treine a inteligência
artificial exatamente é preciso
treinamento como é que isso funciona
a inteligência artificial e ela vai
aprender com isso
voltando por exemplo na caixa de entrada
do e mail de vocês
várias vezes vocês vão lá e clicam a
isso aqui é um spam e quando você fala
que não é um spam ele entende que aquilo
não é um spam
então você está sempre treinando
inteligência artificial
de fato nós somos muito bons em treinar
inteligência artificial porque nós já
treinamos em inteligência artificial
para ganhar de nós em jogos e eu sinto é
que quatro exemplos xadrez poker gol eo
dj ride é um programa de perguntas e
respostas estadunidense e veja que
interessante
nós criamos o jogo nós criamos a
computação
nós criamos a inteligência artificial e
nós treinamos a inteligência artificial
para ganhar de nós em jogo que nós
criamos isso é fantástico
só tem um ponto interessante essa
inteligência artificiais foram treinadas
para ganhar de nós nos jogos
elas foram criadas especificamente para
isso se entregar um texto para que essa
inteligência artificial conseguia ler ou
interpretar provavelmente ela não vai
conseguir porque ela não foi treinada
para isso mas nem sempre esse processo
de treinamento dá certo em 2016
o robô chamada thai foi lançada no
twitter para que ela pudesse aprender
com as pessoas
o objetivo é que ela pudesse aprender a
forma como as pessoas se comunicam e
também que as pessoas pudessem ensinar
qualquer coisa para essas pessoas
infelizmente em menos de 16 horas à
tarde teve que ser teve que ser retirada
do ar porque o que ela estava fazendo
publicações ofensivas racistas e
difamatórias
será que nós não deturpar vamos
o propósito deste robô ao fazer ao
ensinar esse tipo de conteúdo
e será que isso acontece apenas com a
inteligência artificial
a bomba atômica tem um poder de
destruição de milhares ou até milhões de
vidas
não deveríamos nós utilizará a ficção ea
fusão nuclear apenas para poder gerar
energia em usinas tentando trazer um
pouco para mais próximo da nossa
realidade
a internet a internet conectar pessoas
conecta objetos conecta negócios conecta
países e permite a globalização
por outro lado na dark web uma terra sem
lei
você pode comprar armas drogas dados sem
qualquer monitoração e parece muito
distante né do nosso cotidiano
eu disse para vocês que existe algo que
está presente no nosso dia a dia que a
gente pode ter deturpado o seu propósito
quem conhece esse objeto
quem é que já passou algum trote
utilizando o telefone fixo ou um
telefone público
os mais jovens provavelmente não vou
entender essa nossa reação
eles não tiveram essa experiência mas
esse telefone era o principal meio de
comunicação que nós tínhamos um telefone
que ficava colado na parede ligado na
parede
você podia ligar para alguém pra
conversar com alguma pessoa em qualquer
lugar do mundo
apesar que era brincar naquela época só
que nós detectamos o seu propósito
ao passar um trote para uma determinada
pessoa
só que nem sempre a transformação de
utilização de algo foi algo maléfico à
penicilina e um microondas são exemplos
disso
o forno microondas quando ele foi quando
ele surgiu o seu criador na verdade
estava buscando criar um radar de
microondas
só que ele percebeu que aquelas
microondas estava esquentando alimento e
daí surgiu o forno microondas o ser
humano o ser humano é isso
o ser humano é formado de lado os
controversos de ambigüidades e arte nos
ajuda a representar essas ambigüidades
por exemplo no cinema
utilizando exemplos de filmes que são da
atualidade
nós podemos ser tanto aquele tubarão
perigoso assustador quanto nós podemos
ser o simba do relevo o simba é o rei da
selva
ele está preocupado com os animais ele
está preocupado com o meio ambiente
e ele riu na cara do perigo
pensando nesses lados controversos de
nós seres humanos
eu te faço uma pergunta o que nós
estamos dispostos a ensinar a
inteligência artificial
a inteligência artificial é uma folha em
branco e nós podemos dizer que ela pode
que ela não pode fazer e nós estamos
dispostos a fazer com isso a
inteligência artificial
cada vez mais presente no nosso
cotidiano profissional
segundo um estudo do fórum econômico
mundial
o futuro das profissões vai ser
completamente diferente
cerca de 65% das crianças que nasceram
após o ano de 2010 vão trabalhar em
profissões que ainda não existem
uma dessas profissões a qual eu no meio
de treinador de sistema cognitivo vai
ser exatamente aquela pessoa que irá
dizer para a máquina que ela deve que
ela não deve fazer de fato treinar
aquela máquina como nós educadores
estamos preparando essa geração para
isso
será que nós educadores
estamos educando com responsabilidade
essas crianças que no futuro estarão
ensinando a inteligência artificial o
que vocês estão fazendo para preparar a
sua próxima geração
nós estamos criando a realidade que
esses jovens vão viver muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]